cientos de malienses demostraron en las
calles su apoyo al gobierno de
transición y a su líder así migoya en
los últimos dos años malí ha enfrentado
dos golpes de estado
varias potencias y organismos como la
onu y ecowas piden a la junta militar
que gobierna que organice elecciones en
febrero pero los manifestantes dijeron a
estas organizaciones que se ocupen de
sus propios asuntos
[Música]
salimos a manifestar para mostrar a la
opinión nacional e internacional que es
el pueblo de malí quien decide su
destino por eso estamos aquí
los manifestantes también expresaron
consignas contra francia a pesar de años
de operaciones militares dirigidas por
este país contra grupos yihadistas no se
ha logrado detener la violencia en el
país
viene principalmente para apoyar así me
grita quien también está pidiendo la
salida de francia los manifestantes
llevaban banderas de rusia como una
forma de decir que malí puede hacer
tratos con el grupo paramilitar ruso
warner y varios organismos
internacionales han advertido contra
este movimiento diciendo que tal alianza
podría traer más dificultades para los
malienses